what's going on guys this is Rob and the
most powerful being in the history of
Marvel Comics is about to return it's
not the one above all it's not the
beyonder it's not the Living Tribunal or
the molecule man but you will find out
at the end of this video and it is
insane oh my God okay so continuing on
with Gods as always if you need to get
caught up you will find a link to the
gods playlist at the end of this video
we're only two videos in so pretty easy
to catch up but as a little bit of a
refresher here on one side we have the
natural order of things and on the other
side we have the powers that be we know
nothing about them except for the fact
that the Avatar of the powers that be is
a guy named win basically Marvel's
version of John Constantine from DC
Comics and on the other side with the
natural order of things they're
represented by the sent of ours all we
know is that at some point along the
line These two factions went to war they
ended up creating a ceasefire for
reasons that haven't been explained yet
and they've been grudgingly maintaining
that ceasefire ever since but things are
about to pop off so what this does is
this starts off with a girl named Emily
Addison she's one of the most important
people in this comic the ending is
highly relevant to her so what we end up
finding out is that she's what's called
a Cassandra and in effect there have
been five true Cassandras over the
course of the entire history of the
earth more or less we'll find out a
little bit more about them what we're
told is that she's been having the same
dream for the last five
years just continually the exact same
dream but no one is going to act on it
only she can and we'll find out why that
is here in a second what we end up doing
is switching over to the library of
Worlds now like we talked about before
the library of Worlds is a kind of Nexus
in the Multiverse meaning every Universe
across the Multiverse can access the
library of Worlds and it's exactly what
it sounds like a giant library with
endless information on everything you
ever wanteded to know about the history
of the multiv
and everything within the Multiverse
it's hierarchy The Godly pantheons any
and all travesties that have happened
the collapse of the Multiverse leading
up to Secret Wars 2015 it's all there
but what you have here is you have W
Dimitri and doct strange now again
Dimitri technically works for the
natural order of things but he and way
have a kind of friendship and we don't
really know the extent of it but they
kind of work together almost as if like
Demetri is a kind of Protegé assistant
for win most likely keeping an eye on
him and that's it it's likely just kind
of a way to maintain the truce is really
all it is but in this meeting that's
taking place Dimitri is told to stay
here right to stay within the library of
Worlds and Doctor Strange and W go into
the meeting now the cool thing about
this is that what they're told as they
get ready to go in there is that this
frog I know it sounds weird this guy's
well aware of who they are and what he
says is that while the room is normally
reserved for the birth of the universe
that tonight they're presenting a
limited showing of The celus Masterpiece
of the black swans and the black priests
now they're not overly important here
but it is kind of a cool little bit
because you'll likely see them in some
capacity in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe during uh Avengers Secret Wars
and King Dynasty so for those of you
guys who don't know what they are the
black swans were created by Dr Doom in
order to assist him in basically
preventing the early destruction of the
Multiverse by way of the incursions when
it came to the black priests because the
incursions were happening and because
the Multiverse was dying they were kind
of like the Multiverse own defense
system but here's the kicker about this
right so you know how like here in the
United States in any other
English-speaking country that we just
say the word fun that's it right just Fu
n the black priest didn't work that way
instead one priest would say the letter
F and another priest would say the
letter U and a third priest would say
the letter N they didn't memorize words
they memorized letters and they had to
speak in unison to say a word so it was
really cool it was really wonky but
really cool not overly important just
felt like it was kind of a cool little
tidbit here but what it does is it jumps
back to Amelia and again you guys you
guys don't understand okay so again
here's the thing right what we're told
here The Madness of knowing while
everyone else doesn't care to is the
last little death of Amelia and the
birth of her fully realized Cassandra
State she decides to stop telling people
who won listen what is going to happen
whether they are enemies friends or even
family whether she is ignored shouted
down or pied by those who love her
Cassandra is done being ignored she is
done with the wasting of words when Hy
Brazil sunk into the ocean a Cassandra
wept and watched she tried to tell them
when El Dorado burned a Cassandra
screamed and looked away she tried to
tell them it never works they never live
listen because they are so well informed
regarding the lies they believe for the
blind cannot see they can only be saved
and it is time for Cassandra to act now
this is an important thing here right
what we're basically being told
Cassandra can see the future right but
here's the thing this Cassandra that was
there when H Brazil sung into the ocean
was a wholly different person it not
like this girl's Immortal right she's
just inheriting this ability is really
all it is but the Cassandra that saw El
Dorado burning was a different as well
but regardless these are basically women
who can see the future right seemingly
one girl is chosen every however many
billions of years presumably and they
serve a particular purpose here this
girl's purpose is not to save or at
least within the context of this story
not necessarily to save her actions are
actually going to start dooming
everybody but jumping back to when and
dror strange their meeting is actually
with the natural order of things and the
reason for this is because as we talked
about in the previous videos the first
Real Enemy that popped up here was a guy
named cubis core which I still say is
the inet her and we'll find out at least
we'll talk about why that is here in a
second but what this guy did was
initiate a Babylon event basically an
event that could lead to the complete
and total Destruction and ruin of
everything they were able to stop it but
what it did is it led W and Steven
strange on a kind of Trail why would a
guy just appear out of nowhere
brandishing the staff of the Living
Tribunal trying to initiate a universal
and even multiversal cataclysm why would
he do that right it's not something that
a person just does and so there had to
have been a larger motivation here and
so once this kind of uh everybody coming
to terms which is to say like the covars
of the natural Order of Things They Know
Who Doctor Strange is they're aware of
who he is they don't like him and they
don't want him to be here we don't
really know why but the fact remains
that they just don't want him to be a
part of this I would go so far as to say
because Doctor Strange probably
represents chaos I know that it's
something that is most often referred to
or at least associated with the Scarlet
Witch because she channels the power of
cathon and she uses chaos magic but if
you guys remember in Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers The New Avengers where Steven
strange originally denied the existence
of chaos magic in Marvel Comics and that
story when he was in the room with no
words and he couldn't speak he channeled
chaos magic in order to defeat the black
swans So eventually he accepted it was
real and then he used it as a source of
power so I would say that between the
natural order of things and the powers
that be he's likely an enigma either
that or he's the one that kind of sits
and makes sure that the truce is
maintained so neither one of them really
like him whatever the case happens to be
they're aware of him they're just not
fond of him but what's said here at
least by the the cavars is okay yes
we're not happy with Steven strange
being here but there has to be a reason
why W invited him here in the first
place and wi says yes there is and
that's when Steven strange pops up right
he says we interviewed the protom Mage
behind the Babylon event what we learned
was for booting of course they're
talking about cubis core and they say
Cubix core is a reprogrammed Born Again
vessel of the in-betweener that's why I
say I think he's the in-betweener
because this was information that was
released when Marvel originally
announced Gods at San Diego ComicCon so
it's not as though it's something that
we just weren't aware of before this
information had been out there for a
long time but he says the waves of his
actions are neither singular nor without
resonance we believe all the Lesser gods
are moving which implies the greater
gods are preparing to as well the
question is are ours now what he means
when he says lesser gods and greater
Gods is explained when you pick up with
Dmitri who's actually at the bar and
what ends up happening is a guy wanders
in and this guy starts talking to
Dimitri like Dimitri says I haven't seen
you here before and this guy says
because I've never been here before but
you already knew that didn't you Dimitri
krov son of valer and Ivana always
looking to the Stars hoping for a
miraculous re-entry and knowing a return
of any kind is unlikely but you must
keep looking you must when hope is all
you have you dare not lose it now what
you're seeing here is this guy kind of
manifesting and really talking to
Dimitri in his own mind and the reason
is because this guy is a cosmic abstract
what this is is basically the difference
between greater gods and lesser Gods
lesser gods are guys like Odin Thor Zeus
people like that usually gods that are
associated with some kind of planetary
or civilization B based society when it
comes to the greater Gods these are
abstract they are not a byproduct of any
group that's out there and in fact this
is explained quite well by this guy
because Dimitri responds and says I
guess being koi wasn't the move to make
here was it and this guy responds any
acceptable position that one takes
regarding the gods varies wildly
depending on whether you believe in them
or not and Demitri says well it's tough
to be in this line of work and not
believe and that's when this guy says Ah
Faith what a perfect thing now what I
want to point out here is that for
people who are eagle-eyed the identity
of this person is revealed it was
revealed when he was talking to Demitri
in a serpent form and it's also revealed
here when he has a kind of cloak that
momentarily appears over his head but he
says a growing Rarity now but almost all
of humanity was once counted among the
faithful it was what gave man the moral
and intellectual anchor necessary to
separate yourselves from all the other
animals and so you did well done but of
course you didn't deserve too much
credit it was the simple Act of a simple
people after all we gods did the hard
work of creation all you had to do was
not deny it but then that day came and
far too many of you decided to stop
believing mankind a abandoned Gods told
yourselves we were a lie and that you
could replace us with things of your own
creation such as the action of any child
to mimic and then replace their parents
so you people decided to play God but
there was just one problem one forgotten
in all that ignorance and unearned
arrogance while you were made by gods
you were not Gods yourselves what you
were wasn't even close now something
that I want to specify here and really
what he's talking about is Marvel's kind
of interpretation of how various Gods
exists because lesser gods are also
beings like misto the dweller in
darkness right people who came into
existence by whatever Manner and
whatever means when it comes to like the
origin of the asgardians for example
they have a definitive origin in Marvel
Comics but whether it's stories like
Earth X or other things like that Marvel
has played very fast and loose with the
idea that the Asgardian only exist
because Humanity imagined them somewhere
along the line and that imagination gave
them a physical form fearls guys like
dweller in darkness right people like
misto who were really more helll Lords
than anything else they exist because
Humanity imagined them and they came
into existence right there are
definitive origin stories there I don't
want to deny that but again Marvel kind
of dances around that whole thing right
do they exist because they're real or do
they exist because they were created but
the idea of referring to humanity as
wanting to play God that's the notion of
guys like Thor that's the idea of people
like Matthew Malloy people like uh Clyde
wincham the Marquee of death Franklin
Richards people with such astronomical
levels of power whether their powers are
revered by other members of the
superhero Community or they are looked
at as quite literally Gods like the case
of Thor at the end of the day none of
them were ever close right this guy says
for man is too flawed carved from Stone
unyielding evolutionarily static and
built to believe you are hardwired to
follow a captive of idolatry created to
worship and so you replaced us with your
own Creations that you could lift on
high and bow down to politics and
ideology and Persona and anima of All
Sorts but these were not the divinely
inspired creations of gods they were the
flawed work of prot tenders collapsing
at creation built to fail and fail they
did now you have lost faith in them as
well and you have nothing left and so
there's this statement that's made by
Dimitri where he says not sure I buy it
completely and it's a sad story no doubt
but I would think a thing like that
would trouble a God you don't seem
troubled now here's the biggest clue to
this guy's identity he says because I am
not like the other gods I do not desire
praise and worship I have no need for
disciples now while this conversation is
taking place between Demitri and this
guy Steven strange is still having his
meeting with the cavars and wi but then
Cassandra shows up with a gun in hand
and the reason why is because she
intends to end this issue she shows up
here in the library of Worlds now how it
is that she was able to access this is
largely due to a magical object she has
at her disposal how she was able to use
it how she even knew about it I don't
know if it's just ingrain knowledge if
she's just been around for so long
nobody really knows for sure but she
shows up here and Steven strange
immediately panics right like just the
eye of agamotto kicks in right the
allseeing eye like just screams out and
he says suddenly suddenly and all at
once we kiss the edge of disaster
outside we have to hurry and so this guy
this mysterious man starts speaking
again because there's this kind of idea
that this guy has followers right and he
says it's true my numbers grow for while
I care nothing for the praise and
worship of man there are those who seek
me out and find my altar they receive no
special dispensation no special favor
from my hand right as this is happening
Cassandra opens fire and she recollects
back right all the little Clues and the
things that she'd put together basically
telling her exactly where she needed to
go because in the hand of one of the
people in this library of Worlds is a
little Crystal no bigger than a golf
ball but while this happens this guy
says no to them at least to his
followers I give them the same gift I
give to everyone and it is the greatest
gift any human can receive the
permission to do anything you want
because nothing matters at all while
this is happening literally when like
realizes who this guy is which
technically Demitri did as well I just
didn't include that in the story because
I didn't want to spoil this guy's
identity Steven strange also seems to
know who this guy is and this is when
the reveal comes it's the greatest
ending to a comic that I have read in
recent memory this guy talking directly
to Cassandra says look closely child see
my face and see the inevitable Ash of
annihilation for I am the end I am
Oblivion my time is now that's right
ladies and gentlemen Oblivion the sum
total of nothingness the guy who will
outlive everything in existence when the
one above all dies the Living Tribunal
dies the Multiverse dies and every God
therein dies he is all that will remain
this guy is back in Marvel Comics with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end make sure you guys
click this playlist and get caught up on
gods and I will catch you all later
peace